welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka you friendly
neighborhood spider-man and it looks
like we may get some answers have the
emcee use biggest questions with the
release of the Eternals next November
the Marvel Studios movie is reportedly
set to take place 35,000 years before
the events of Captain America the First
Avenger and the film will be setting up
many of the big moments that will happen
in the MCU whilst there are rumors that
a younger version of Thanos will pop up
in the film as he himself as an eternal
the movie could also potentially
Chronicle how the celestial had nowhere
that appears in the film guardians of
the galaxy and infinity war came to be
throughout this video I'll be going over
my theories on which celestial the head
is and how it could come to be in the
film
now spoilers ahead if I'm right about
all of this but those who paid close
attention to the Disney d23 event last
month may have seen the concept art for
the Eternals movie that was shown at the
expo and after trying to identify the
celestial it looks to line up a lot with
the head at nowhere looking at them side
by side I think it's pretty safe to say
that these are the same character and
the Eternals could potentially show the
creatures death either at the hands of
the heroes or some other force we have
seen from clips in guardians of the
galaxy that the Celestials were some
pretty big forces in the galaxy that all
died out long ago in my opinion the
Eternals would probably showcase their
downfall and could even put them as some
of the enemies that the characters have
to go head-to-head with the celestial
itself actually looks extremely similar
to the character Madonna which is one of
the most notable ones amongst the
species this character is in earth-616
native and originally appeared in a
hundred and fourteen ad whilst
destroying a great Chinese Kingdom that
was the palace of zhang heng now what's
most interesting about Madonna is that
during this she not only revealed that
earth was housing the celestial egg but
also that she was carrying a child
childbearing was actually forbidden
amongst the Celestials and at the time
the birth could have killed her if she
decided to go through with it
Madonna did eventually settle on giving
for the child and she did this on the
son as either giving birth where on
earth or the moon could cause disastrous
gravitational effects for the planet but
Donna did die during the birth and after
being bathed in the sun's energy she was
destroyed which could line up with how
her head eventually drifted throughout
space and came to settle as the market
that eventually became nowhere another
interesting aspect of the concept are is
that we can see the creature looking
over what seems to be the Earth and Moon
so yeah
this makes a lot of sense the film could
potentially have this as a plot motif
and Chloe's our director of the Eternals
has stated that the movie will span
thousands of years so this could line up
with the ancient Chinese storyline I
definitely think that the concept art
lines of heavily with the head and
though the film might not stick to the
source material and the birthing
storyline it is possible that the
Eternals may witness the death of
Madonna at some point in the film and
allow her head to settle in space where
the location eventually becomes
established now this is purely a fan
theory but I do think that the
Celestials will play a huge part in the
Eternals movie and one could assume that
Marvel have been slowly setting these
characters up throughout the films by
giving us glimpses at them we all know
the MCU is incredible at putting the
pieces in place early on to pay off in
later movies and with the Celestials
taking up a huge part in the marketing
and concept of the film I definitely
think we will see somewhat of the rise
and fall of the creatures and it makes
sense to at least showcase the one that
makes it to modern day even if it's just
the head the Celestials are a
fascinating race of creatures that type
very closely to the origin of the
Infinity stones so I'm glad that Marvel
are using these to flesh out the
universe's most interesting MacGuffins
as this will add a lot of backstory as
to why Tanis was so eager to collect all
of them as part of this plan irish ham
was also spotted amongst the concept art
at d23 and for those who don't know he's
actually the leader of the Celestials so
it's possible that he could play a big
part in the movie Irish em killed a lot
of the deviant race of the Eternals
which Stannis is actually a member of
and this is why he has purple skin and
era Shem is also responsible for the
flood that appeared during Noah's Ark
era Shem invaded earth and it could be
during this that Madonna
with him and then please to the Sun
think of birth after discovering that
she's pregnant there's definitely a lot
of ways that the phone could go but I
can perhaps see the Eternals having to
defend Earth from the Celestials and
Madonna fleeing in the process while
Sarah Shem goes head-to-head with the
heroes either way I think we are in for
a real treat with the film when it
releases next year and I can't wait to
see if my theory on the whole thing is
correct
obviously I loved hear your thoughts on
this and if you agree with me or not
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of the news that Sony will let Disney
use spider-man and the MCU as long as he
can also appear in venom which would be
linked at the end I go over everything
you need to know about the deal updates
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books and you can follow
me on twitter at definition why teen
it's the best way to get in touch with
me and it's the perfect places just new
videos and content so hopefully I see
you over there after this you've also
only got 7 days left to enter our John
wick 3 blu-ray giveaway which closes on
the 10th of September all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is to
be subscribed to the channel like this
video and leave your thoughts on the
celestial theory in the comments below
the competition is running across all
videos so the more comments you leave
the better chances the woody will be
announced on the 10th so best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you liked it subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
peace
[Music]
[Music]